patrick swayze would have been 70 years
old today and we miss him every day
every day and his classic dirty dancing
will turn 35 this sunday in honor of
both milestones only i spoke with
patrick's widow lisa niemi who is
sharing private memories
[Music]
when you think of patrick what do you
think of most
oh my gosh i think it's because of the
35th anniversary and
his birthday it's a little hard for me
because
i don't think there's anything i don't
miss about him it's all the little
things that just laugh
it's the sound of his boy i paid her to
say that though i feel like he's with me
every day we had a great ride and
there's so much to be grateful for
patrick and lisa were married for 34
years before he lost his battle with
pancreatic cancer in 2009. patrick was
just 57. i dream that everyone diagnosed
will be fortunate enough to have hope
this was one of patrick's final public
appearances the cancer made him
noticeably thinner but he was filled
with courage and praying for a cure
patrick's incredible legacy lives on
through his movies but there is one
movie that really does stand out it's
dirty dancing
[Music]
[Applause]
that lift with jennifer gray what did he
share about what it took to accomplish
that oh patrick he had that down forever
we called it the angel of course patrick
loved showing off and he was strong
enough to do all that stuff yeah so when
they wanted to pull out a great lift he
says i got one for you
the 1987 surprise hit catapulted patrick
into full-blown icon status but when he
was offered a reported six million
dollars for a sequel he turned it down
absolutely he would not do it again
unless it was absolutely perfect patrick
had a high standard and he wasn't gonna
do it just for the money all these years
later jennifer gray is carrying on their
legacy with a dirty dancing sequel what
do you think about it and what would
patrick have hoped for i don't think he
could ever absolutely duplicate
something
you know i think you always have to
start fresh but if they gonna do it i
hope it's the absolute best and it has
its own source of inspiration jennifer
will both star and executive produce the
film she told et it is a daunting task
carrying baby's legacy without her
irreplaceable dance partner
to make a movie without patrick
is already
an enormous challenge
somebody close to me
it will never be that movie and it
should never try to be that movie
nobody puts baby in the corner
the sequel is set to arrive in theaters
in february of 2024. this is my dad's
face that's yours that's cha-cha plot
details have not been released but
swayze's beloved character johnny is
said to loom large over the story i'm so
grateful
to have
had him as my johnny the second
he came in to do
the screen test with me it was just
crazy
and that lightning in a bottle chemistry
is just one of the reasons this
coming-of-age classic still resonates
today it's a feeling
a heartbeat
google
google
during his time with e.t the screen
legend shared so many behind-the-scenes
secrets including
this iconic scene was actually just
patrick and jennifer messing around
before a take
the time of my life
tons and tons of things were improv when
i'm teaching jennifer and i'm getting
frustrated and i'm trying to trying to
get her to be serious and she's laughing
or giggling the moment i run my hand
down her you know down her arm and
that really is me getting frustrated
he's like oh my g would you just
stop
[Music]